la santé mentale ça me concerne pas moi
je suis bien dans ma tête donc alors non
non déjà la santé mentale c'est pas
juste le fait de ne pas avoir de
maladies mentale donc déjà tu peux être
bien dans ta tête et faire face à des
difficultés quand même à un moment ou un
autre ensuite c'est très large ça peut
aller du petit coup de déprime à la
dépression ça peut être une phobie des
difficultés à s'organiser de l'anxiété
ça peut être 1000 trucs et pas besoin
d'avoir des antécédents ou une fragilité
psychologique ou je sais pas quoi ça
peut arriver absolument à tout le monde
sans qu'on s'y attendre en France il y a
13 millions de personnes qui ont une
maladie mentale ça fait une personne sur
cinq et il y a une personne sur quatre
qui prend des médicaments comme les
antidépresseurs les antiolytiques etc si
vous voulez un autre chiffre le suicide
c'est la première cause de mortalité
chez les 15 35 ans donc pour être clair
on sera toutes et tous concernés par un
problème de santé mentale à un moment ou
un autre plus ou moins sévère bien sûr
mais tout le monde sera concerné et si
c'est pas à titre personnel ce sera pour
un projet